Georg Elser,
Henning von Tresckow,
Fabian von Shlabrendorff,
Rudolf von Gersdorff,
et Claus von Stauffenberg.
Un simple ouvrier
et quatre officiers aristocrates.
Cinq hommes
qui ont refusé l'indicible.
Cinq hommes d'honneur.
Cinq hommes qui ont voulu tuer Hitler.
Mais ils ne le savaient pas,
Hitler était protégé...
par la chance du Diable.
Voici leur histoire.
C'est en chanson
que les troupes allemandes
s'enfoncent dans les plaines russes.
Hitler a emmené l'Allemagne
à la conquête du monde
en chantant.
Il avait promis à ses hommes la victoire.
Il les a conduits
au cœur de l'apocalypse.
Les chants de gloire se sont tus
dans l'enfer de l'hiver russe
et les rêves fous d'Hitler
se sont dispersés
dans des vents glacés.
Hitler...
est un imbécile.
Et un criminel.
Nous devons mettre fin à cette société.
Il ne s'agit pas de dire la vérité
à Hitler,
il s'agit de le tuer.
Et je suis prêt à le faire.
N'y a-t-il pas un seul officier
dans le QG d'Hitler
qui soit capable d'abattre cette bête ?
L'histoire avait voulu les oublier,
mais des hommes de bonne volonté,
quelques-uns
de ses plus proches officiers
ont bien tenté d'abattre cette bête.
Depuis 1933,
et la prise du pouvoir par Adolf Hitler,
plus de 30 tentatives d'attentat
pour le mettre hors d'état de nuire
ont échoué.
Car Hitler est bien accompagné
par la chance du Diable.
Hitler, nouveau chancelier du Reich,
s'est octroyé le titre
de Führer du peuple allemand.
Ce qui veut dire "le guide".
Il s'est aussi proclamé
chef suprême de l'armée.
C'est à sa seule personne
qu'il fait jurer obéissance et fidélité.
Un terrible pacte lie désormais l'armée
et ses officiers
à Hitler.
Nous nous sentions tous
très mal à l'aise.
Car suivant la bonne tradition militaire
prussienne,
nous avions désormais
des obligations à l'égard d'un homme
qui nous était étranger et détestable.
Mais qui pouvait alors deviner
qu'Hitler profiterait de ce serment
pour nous enfermer
dans des ordres criminels ?
Car rares sont les officiers
réprouvant les méthodes nazies.
Hitler est à la fin des années 30
un homme adulé
par près de 90 % de ses concitoyens.
Les autres se taisent
ou sont en prison.
Le tour de force
d'un magicien maléfique
et c'est un pays tout entier
qui marche la croix gammée dans la nuit.
À Munich, un homme a décidé d'agir.
Si personne ne peut stopper Hitler,
lui va oser.
Il s'appelle Johann Georg Elser.
Ouvrier qualifié
et sympathisant communiste,
Elser, depuis trois mois,
caché dans son atelier,
prépare sa bombe.
Les conditions en Allemagne
ne pouvaient être modifiées
que par l'élimination
de la direction actuelle.
Par direction,
j'entendais les supérieurs.
Je veux dire Hitler,
Goering et Goebbels.
J'avais la conviction
que l'élimination de ces trois hommes
permettrait à d'autres
d'entrer au gouvernement
et veillerait
à améliorer les conditions sociales
de la classe ouvrière.
Elser n'est pas seul.
Le général Beck,
commandant en chef de l'état-major
de la Wehrmacht prépare un putsch
avec quelques officiers
pour renverser ce Führer
qu'ils méprisent.
Hitler les a contraints à la démission
et après l'Autriche
et la Tchécoslovaquie,
il lance ses troupes
à l'assaut de la Pologne,
le 1er septembre 1939.
Rien ne semble
résister à l'armée allemande.
Et les Stukas
et les bombardiers du Führer,
expérimentent pour la première fois
des bombardements de terreur
sur Varsovie.
Une véritable répétition générale
et les civils en sont
les premières victimes.
Elser, à Munich,
prépare son attentat.
Il est le seul, désormais,
à pouvoir stopper Hitler;
J'avais appris que la prochaine réunion
à laquelle assisterait la direction
se tiendrait
le 8 et le 9 novembre à Munich,
à la Bürgerbräukeller.
Je quittais la petite salle
où je m'asseyais presque toujours
à la même place.
Je passais par le vestiaire,
pour déboucher dans la grande salle,
qui n'était jamais fermée à clé,
et je me cachais dans le cagibi,
situé près de la sortie,
et dont la porte
était masquée par un grand paravent.
À la brasserie,
après avoir dîné
et s'être laissé enfermer,
Georg Elser va, pendant 35 nuits,
préparer sa cache
dans la colonne près du pupitre
où Hitler doit tenir son discours.
Enfin, le 6 novembre,
il peut installer sa bombe
dans la cavité.
Le mécanisme est réglé
pour que l'engin explose
le 8 novembre entre 21h15 et 21h30.
Dans la soirée du 8 novembre,
Hitler embarque
à bord de son avion privé
direction Munich.
Il est un des premiers hommes politiques
à préférer l'avion au train.
Il peut ainsi prendre la parole
le même jour
devant différentes assemblées.
Et dans cet avion
spécialement aménagé,
Hitler peut tout à son aise travailler
à la rédaction de ses discours.
... dans la puissance de ce peuple.
Il n'est pas encore 20 h
quand le Führer fait son entrée
dans la salle comble
de la Bürgerbräukeller.
Il monte à la tribune à 20h08.
Mais, surprise,
son discours se termine à 20h58.
Victoire !
Hitler quitte la salle à 21h09.
Il semble pressé, sombre,
et préoccupé.
Hans Bauer, son pilote,
l'a prévenu qu'en raison de la météo,
il doit rejoindre Berlin par le train.
Pour une question d'horaire,
Hitler a raccourci son discours
de moitié.
Ce qui bouleverse
le planning minutieux de Georg Elser.
L'explosion a lieu à 21h20
comme prévu.
Huit personnes sont tuées
et 63 sont blessées.
Hitler, lui, est en route pour Berlin.
Dès 22 h,
l'enquête permet de découvrir
les restes d'une bombe artisanale.
Les explosifs sont ceux
utilisés dans les carrières
et le mécanisme à retardement
est celui d'une pendule.
Ces informations
facilitent les recherches
et dans la journée du 9 novembre,
tout est résolu.
Georg Elser est arrêté,
alors qu'il tente
de passer la frontière suisse.
Je me suis seulement
livré à des considérations
quant aux moyens
permettant d'améliorer
les conditions sociales
de la classe ouvrière
et d'éviter une guerre.
Je n'y étais incité par personne.
Je n'ai pas été influencé
en quoi que ce soit dans ce sens.
Je n'ai jamais entendu
de conversations similaires.
Je n'ai pas non plus entendu dire
à la Radio de Moscou
qu'il fallait renverser
le gouvernement allemand
et le régime.
Je l'ai fait pour que plus aucun sang
ne soit versé.
J'ai agi seul.
Je n'y ai été incité par personne.
Je n'ai jamais eu de doute
sur le bien-fondé de mon action.
Pour le pouvoir allemand,
il est impensable qu'un homme seul,
un homme du peuple,
ait été aussi près de réussir.
Alors, dans la presse,
est exhibée la photo
de deux agents secrets britanniques
qui auraient tenté
d'assassiner le Führer
avec l'aide d'Elser.
Une manipulation.
Un faux avéré.
Georg Elser, le justicier solitaire,
est envoyé en camp
dans l'attente d'un procès
qui doit dénoncer le rôle des Anglais.
Sans les caprices de la météo,
Hitler aurait dû mourir.
L'attentat raté est une véritable aubaine
pour le Führer.
Il dit être sous la protection
de la divine Providence.
Au lendemain des funérailles
des victimes de l'attentat,
un rapport établi par le service
des renseignements des SS
constate :
"Sa tentative d'assassinat à Munich
a grandement
renforcé la notion de solidarité
au sein de la population
et l'amour pour le Führer a grandi."
Hitler est devenu un personnage
quasi mythique.
Malgré les réticences de son état-major,
il est temps pour Hitler
de s'attaquer à l'Ouest.
Le 10 mai 1940, il lance ses troupes
à l'assaut de la Hollande,
de la Belgique et de la France.
Réputée la meilleure du monde,
l'armée française
est balayée en cinq semaines.
L'audace du plan allemand
et la brutalité du Blitzkrieg
ont raison des troupes françaises,
trahies
par un commandement défaillant.
C'est la débâcle.
Le gouvernement français capitule
face à Hitler.
La défaite est consommée
avec la demande d'armistice
du 20 juin du maréchal Pétain.
Pour Adolf Hitler,
la victoire est totale.
Le général Keitel, chef d'état-major,
appelle désormais son Führer
"Grösster Feldherr aller Zeiten".
Le plus grand chef militaire
de tous les temps.
Hitler a gagné son insensé pari.
Il est le maître de la France
et de l'Europe.
Pour le conquérant,
il est temps d'explorer
son nouveau domaine.
Escorté de caméramans
du service de la propagande,
le dimanche 23 juin,
à 6 h du matin,
Hitler entame une visite éclair de Paris.
L'Arc de triomphe,
l'Opéra, la Madeleine,
la place de la Concorde,
les Invalides
et le tombeau de Napoléon
et enfin, le cortège s'arrête
à l'esplanade du Trocadéro.
Là, Hitler pose pour les caméras,
face à la tour Eiffel.
Quelques mois plus tard,
des officiers sous les ordres
du feldmarschall Erwin von Witzleben
prévoient d'abattre Hitler
lors d'une parade
sur les Champs-Élysées.
Mais Hitler n'est jamais revenu
à Paris.
Une fois la guerre gagnée à l'Ouest,
Hitler se tourne vers l'Est.
Il est temps de s'attaquer à l'URSS.
L'empire judéo-bolchevique,
comme il l'appelle.
Le 22 juin 1941,
aux premières lueurs de l'aube,
débute l'opération Barbarossa.
Hitler lance 125 divisions
à l'assaut de l'Union soviétique.
Précédés de milliers d'avions
qui écrasent en quelques heures
les défenses soviétiques,
trois immenses groupes d'armée,
cinq millions d'hommes
et 4 300 chars
enfoncent l'Armée rouge
et se ruent au nord vers Leningrad,
au centre vers Moscou
et au sud vers les plaines à blé
de l'Ukraine
et le pétrole du Caucase.
La plus grande invasion militaire
de tous les temps.
Un véritable rouleau compresseur.
Leningrad est à portée de canon,
Moscou à moins de 100 kilomètres
et Kiev est tombé.
Rien ne semble pouvoir arrêter Hitler
sur ce qu'il nomme
"la conquête de son espace vital".
Les pertes de l'Armée rouge
sont colossales.
Et les prisonniers
se comptent par millions.
Peu survivront à la barbarie nazie.
À l'état-major de la Wehrmacht,
le maréchal Keitel a fait distribuer
une ordonnance à ses officiers.
Un véritable permis de tuer.
Pire même.
D'assassiner.
Un texte terrifiant
atterrit sur mon bureau.
Il portait la signature d'Hitler
et ordonnait que tous les commissaires
et chefs politiques de l'Armée rouge
qui tombaient entre nos mains
soient livrés au service de sécurité
afin d'être éliminés
ou abattus sur place.
La guerre est monstrueuse.
Mais menée par Hitler,
elle le sera plus encore.
Chaque unité combattante
de la Wehrmacht
doit être suivie d'un groupe de SS,
les Einsatzgruppen,
chargés du nettoyage.
Arrestations brutales,
assassinats et exécutions de masse,
tout leur est autorisé.
En toute impunité.
Et en dehors de toute juridiction.
Leurs victimes : les communistes
et surtout, les populations juives.
Nous sommes des soldats.
Pas des assassins.
Tant que je serai le chef
du groupe d'armées Centre,
il n'y aura pas d'exécutions
d'agents politiques ou de prisonniers.
Que plus jamais ne puisse
se produire une telle chose.
Nous devons donc agir maintenant.
Dans cent ans,
le monde se souviendra
de ce que nous avons fait.
Ils devaient se déshabiller,
creuser leurs fosses,
et attendre le coup de grâce.
Ils sont près d'un million de victimes,
hommes, femmes et enfants,
de ce que l'histoire appellera
"la Shoah par balles".
Les hommes qui nous gouvernent
ne sont à mes yeux
qu'associations de malfaiteurs.
Leurs méthodes criminelles
pratiquées au sein du Reich,
comme dans les pays conquis,
sont indignes d'un pays civilisé.
Ils déshonorent l'Allemagne,
tout en la menant à sa perte.
Schlabrendorff est l'adjoint
du colonel Henning von Tresckow
à l'état-major du front de l'Est.
Depuis deux ans, von Tresckow,
horrifié par les crimes
commis par les nazis,
a réuni autour de lui
un groupe de fidèles.
Tous prêts à éliminer Hitler.
Les tentatives vont être nombreuses,
mais toutes vont échouer.
La sécurité s'est renforcée
autour du Führer.
Ses déplacements et son agenda
sont tenus secrets.
Schmundt,
l'officier d'état-major d'Hitler,
m'avait expliqué
que tous les organes vitaux d'Hitler
étaient protégés
par un gilet pare-balles,
efficace contre les munitions
de petits calibres.
Sa casquette était doublée
d'une plaque de métal.
Le monde retient son souffle
quand, de juillet 1942 à février 1943,
les armées allemandes et soviétiques
s'affrontent à Stalingrad.
La bataille de Stalingrad
est la plus sanglante
et la plus coûteuse en vies humaines
de l'histoire.
Six mois de combats
et deux millions de morts.
Elle est devenue un symbole.
Et le Führer a interdit à ses troupes
tout mouvement de repli.
Encerclés, submergés,
vaincus par les Soviétiques, le froid
et la faim,
le 2 février 1943,
plus de 90 000 Allemands se rendent.
Dont 2 500 officiers,
24 généraux et un maréchal.
Friedrich von Paulus.
Stalingrad met fin au mythe
de l'invincibilité d'Hitler.
Après la défaite de Stalingrad,
les officiers
sont nombreux à comprendre
qu'ils se sont laissés emporter
par un fou furieux.
Malgré leur serment de fidélité,
certains pensent
se retourner contre leur maître,
le Führer.
Au quartier général,
à Smolensk,
le colonel Henning von Tresckow
attend pour agir.
Nous avions appris
qu'Hitler envisageait de rendre visite
au QG de Kluge.
L'occasion était trop belle.
Les hauts chefs militaires allemands
n'étaient pas en mesure
de prendre l'initiative d'un coup d'État.
Ils accepteraient seulement
de suivre un ordre.
Je décidais donc d'assumer
l'amorçage initial.
Nous ne pouvons absolument pas
agir autrement
si nous voulons
conserver un tant soit peu
l'estime de nous-mêmes.
Cela doit se faire.
Nous nous chargeâmes nous-mêmes
des ultimes préparatifs.
Tresckow
avait imaginé le stratagème suivant :
pour être sûr de l'effet,
nous prîmes non pas un,
mais deux explosifs.
Nous en fîmes un paquet.
Dont la forme ressemblait
à deux flacons de cognac.
Puis,
il nous fallait confectionner le paquet
de manière
à pouvoir actionner le détonateur
sans détruire l'emballage.
Venus de Prusse orientale,
deux Condors identiques
se préparent à atterrir.
Par mesure de protection,
personne ne sait
dans lequel se trouve le Führer.
Le convoi est accompagné
d'une escadrille de chasse.
Préparez vos fusils !
La matinée se passe
en entretien à l'état-major.
Puis, le déjeuner
est servi au mess des officiers.
Baissez vos armes !
À table,
il fallut supporter
la bonne humeur d'Hitler,
heureux d'être au contact
d'authentiques soldats.
Le Führer avait fait venir
son cuisinier personnel
et son médecin,
chargé de goûter ses plats.
Hitler se méfie de tous.
Alors, 12 goûteurs
sont à son service.
Garde personnel de la SS,
cuisiniers et médecin
le suivent à chaque voyage.
Penché sur son assiette,
les coudes sur la table,
ne se redressant
que pour avaler une gorgée,
Hitler offrait un spectacle méprisable.
... une ville allemande.
Il fallait agir vite.
Le Führer allait repartir.
J'approchais donc
le lieutenant-colonel Brandt
qui devait voyager
dans le même avion.
Avec nonchalance,
je lui demandais s'il voulait bien
se charger d'un colis pour moi.
Un pari stupide
perdu avec le colonel Stieff,
commandant suprême
de l'armée de terre,
et qui m'avait coûté
deux bouteilles de cognac.
Voilà mon prétexte.
Merci beaucoup.
Préparez la voiture !
La voiture est prête !
Attention !
Le colonel Brandt a accepté
de se charger du colis.
Reste à Schlabrendorff
à amorcer la bombe.
- Brandt !
- Départ !
Je vous remercie.
Soulagés, et avec la conscience
du devoir accompli,
Tresckow et Schlabrendorff
regardent décoller
le Condor FW du Führer
vers ce qu'ils espèrent l'enfer.
Nous n'ignorions pas
que l'avion d'Hitler comportait
un dispositif spécial de sûreté.
Il se composait
de plusieurs cellules isolées.
La place d'Hitler était blindée
et conçue pour permettre
un saut immédiat en parachute.
La charge d'explosif devait suffire
à déchiqueter tout l'appareil.
Et même si cela ne se produisait pas,
il arracherait
un morceau du fuselage si important
que l'avion s'écraserait
de toute façon au sol.
Accompagné de sa doublure,
et escorté
d'une escadrille de chasseurs,
l'avion d'Hitler a mis le cap sur Berlin.
Le colonel Brandt ignore
qu'il a embarqué une bombe
dans l'appareil de son Führer.
INTERDIT À LA VENTE
Au quartier général de Smolensk,
l'attente près du poste de radio
met les nerfs à rude épreuve.
L'explosion devait avoir lieu
30 minutes plus tard.
Selon nos calculs,
l'avion devait se trouver près de Minsk
à ce moment-là.
À chaque moment,
nous espérions recevoir un message
de l'un des chasseurs d'escorte
annonçant la perte
de l'appareil du Führer
Mais rien ne vint.
Enfin, après deux heures,
un message de routine
en provenance de Berlin
annonce que le Führer,
après une visite d'inspection
sur le front de l'Est,
est bien rentré en Allemagne
et a regagné son QG à l'heure prévue.
Il fallait nous rendre à l'évidence.
Aussi stupéfiant
que cela puisse paraître,
notre attentat avait échoué.
Tresckow et moi-même
étions littéralement assommés.
Pour les deux conspirateurs,
il est vital
de récupérer le colis
qui peut les accuser.
Schlabrendorff prend l'avion
pour Berlin
avec deux véritables
bouteilles de cognac
et effectue l'échange
en expliquant au colonel Brandt
qu'il y avait eu méprise.
Schlabrendorff et Tresckow
trouveront une autre occasion
pour leurs deux bombes.
Une cérémonie commémorative
doit avoir lieu au musée de l'Armée
pour les héros
tombés au champ de bataille.
Le Heldengedentag.
C'est une occasion à ne pas rater.
Selon le protocole,
le Führer doit y assister
en compagnie de Heinrich Himmler,
et de Hermann Goering.
Celui d'entre nous
qui est résolu à abattre Hitler
doit être prêt à sacrifier sa propre vie.
À l'Arsenal,
le musée de l'Armée
sur Unter den Linden,
Hitler est accueilli
par Hermann Goering,
Wilhelm Keitel et Heinrich Himmler.
C'est mon ami,
le colonel von Gersdorff
qui, après avoir réfléchi un instant,
m'a dit :
"J'accepterai cette mission.
Je l'accepterai
pour le salut de la patrie."
Comme chaque année,
la cérémonie débute par un concert
dans la cour d'honneur.
Au programme,
la Symphonie No 7 de Bruckner.
J'ai suggéré que le volontaire
qui accepterait l'exécution du projet
mettrait une bombe
dans chaque manche de son manteau
et devrait ensuite,
après avoir déclenché la mise à feu,
s'approcher autant que possible
du Führer.
De cette manière, l'homme
qui consentait au sacrifice de sa vie
avait le maximum de chance
de réussir son projet.
Après le traditionnel concert,
Hitler doit se rendre dans le musée
et visiter une exposition
de trophées et d'armes
pris aux Soviétiques.
C'est le colonel Gersdorff
qui doit servir de guide.
Pour pouvoir saluer du bras droit,
Gersdorff place une seule bombe
dans sa manche gauche.
Après avoir activé
le détonateur chimique,
il lui faut 15 minutes pour agir.
À ce moment,
Gersdorff sera près d'Hitler
et tout sera accompli.
Lorsque le cortège du Führer
a pénétré dans le hall d'exposition,
le général Schmundt
s'est approché de moi
et m'a prévenu qu'Hitler
consacrerait moins de cinq minutes
à l'inspection des trophées.
Ainsi donc,
il était matériellement impossible
de mener le projet à exécution.
Il me fallait au moins dix minutes.
Une visite de cinq minutes.
Les cinq minutes les plus longues
de la vie de Gersdorff.
Il a accepté le sacrifice suprême.
Se faire sauter avec le dictateur.
Mais pratiquement jeter un regard
sur les trophées,
le Führer visite l'exposition
au pas de course.
En moins de dix minutes.
Une visite éclair.
C'est un Hitler pressé,
comme s'il avait
eu connaissance d'un danger,
qui, à la surprise de sa suite,
quitte l'exposition.
Une visite bien trop rapide
pour le détonateur.
Gersdorff n'a que le temps
de se précipiter aux toilettes
pour désamorcer sa machine infernale.
Gersdorff a la vie sauve,
mais l'attentat a échoué.
Le deuxième échec
en moins de huit jours.
Hitler, ignorant le danger mortel
auquel il vient d'échapper,
salue les troupes
réunies en son honneur
sur le boulevard Unter den Linden.
Dans les semaines qui suivent,
le Führer va encore échapper
à deux tentatives d'assassinat.
Alors que l'Allemagne perd la guerre
sur le front est
et qu'à l'ouest s'annonce
le débarquement allié,
Hitler offre au général Rommel,
pour ses exploits
à la tête de l'Afrika Corps,
son bâton de maréchal.
Erwin Rommel est un
des personnages les plus populaires
de la propagande cinématographique
nazie.
Pour les Allemands,
il est devenu une icône.
Tresckow
et les autres officiers de la Wehrmacht
qui s'opposent à Hitler
voudraient avoir à leurs côtés
cet homme que toute l'Allemagne adore
et pourrait suivre.
Mais Rommel,
comme beaucoup d'officiers
de haut rang,
s'estime tenu par le serment
qui le lie au Führer.
Durant l'hiver et le printemps 1944,
Hitler affecte Rommel,
son officier préféré,
au renforcement du mur de l'Atlantique.
Un ouvrage défensif
censé empêcher tout débarquement
sur les côtes françaises.
Un ouvrage vain,
car ils étaient attendus
et ils sont venus,
comme l'avait prédit
le maréchal Rommel.
"Le débarquement aura lieu ici,
en Normandie,
et ce jour sera le jour le plus long."
Le 6 juin 1944,
1 213 bateaux de guerre,
736 navires de soutien,
864 cargos
et 4 126 engins et péniches
débarquent 20 000 véhicules
et 156 000 hommes
sur les plages de Normandie.
Les Alliés ont mis pied en France
et rien ne pourra plus les arrêter
dans leur marche vers Berlin.
Rommel sait la bataille perdue
et désire même négocier
une paix séparée avec les Alliés.
Montgomery, l'Anglais,
et Eisenhower, l'Américain.
La résistance allemande
et les officiers conspirateurs
ont sondé Rommel.
Mais il hésite.
Il sait qu'un attentat
se prépare contre le Führer.
Il adhère peut-être à la conspiration,
mais il pose ses exigences.
Hitler doit être arrêté et jugé.
Rommel est
résolument hostile à un assassinat.
Ce 17 juillet, fidèle à son habitude,
il est en tournée d'inspection
sur le front.
Comme toujours,
l'adjudant Daniel est au volant.
et le capitaine Elmut Lang
surveille le ciel.
Les avions anglo-américains
sèment la terreur.
Il est presque impossible de circuler.
Mais Rommel n'en a cure.
Lui que l'on surnomme
"le général des grands chemins".
Il est 17 h
quand une patrouille de Spitfire
repère le véhicule du maréchal
sur la route de Vimoutiers.
Deux avions ennemis s'approchent.
Ils se dirigent vers nous
et sont en position d'attaque.
Les deux pilotes décident de descendre
pour une passe en rase-mottes.
Le capitaine Lang a vu les deux avions
fondre sur eux.
Il est trop tard pour trouver un abri.
Rommel ordonne à Daniel d'accélérer,
de tenter de se dégager.
Rien à faire
sur cette longue ligne droite.
La voiture est déjà
dans le collimateur des chasseurs.
Les mitrailleuses crépitent
et les balles frappent le véhicule.
Daniel s'écroule.
Mort.
Transpercé par une balle.
La voiture, hors de contrôle,
entame une terrible embardée
et verse dans un fossé.
Les chasseurs sont
déjà remontés vers les nuages.
Rommel gît sur l'herbe normande,
grièvement blessé au crâne.
Pour Stauffenberg, Tresckow
et la résistance,
c'est une perte irréparable.
Car ils se trouvent privés
de l'officier le plus populaire
et le plus compétent
qu'ils auraient pu gagner à leur cause.
Mais il est trop tard pour renoncer.
Puisque les généraux
n'ont maintenant abouti à rien,
c'est aux colonels de s'en occuper.
En tant qu'officier,
nous nous devons
de sauver l'Allemagne.
Nous avons relevé ce défi devant Dieu
et notre conscience,
et cela doit être fait.
Parce que cet homme, Hitler,
est le mal absolu.
Ce jour du 20 juillet 1944
doit être enfin le bon.
À Berlin, le colonel von Stauffenberg
et son aide de camp,
Werner von Haeften,
embarquent pour Rastenburg,
la Tanière du Loup.
Dans sa sacoche,
Stauffenberg emporte deux bombes.
Les mêmes bombes qui ont servi
aux attentats manqués
de Smolensk et Berlin.
Colonel et comte
de la vieille noblesse prussienne,
von Stauffenberg est un
de ces officiers de grande famille
qui a vu l'arrivée d'Hitler avec bonheur.
Brillant officier, il sert
sous les ordres du maréchal Rommel
en Afrique du Nord.
Là, en 1943,
il est sévèrement blessé
et perd un œil,
sa main droite
et deux doigts de sa main gauche.
Sa longue convalescence
se transforme
en une douloureuse remise en question.
Alors, sa conscience et son honneur
lui imposent d'agir.
Et il rejoint la résistance
animée par Tresckow.
Depuis sa nomination à l'état-major,
von Stauffenberg
est devenu précieux à la résistance.
Car il peut régulièrement
s'approcher d'Hitler.
C'est lui qui fait parvenir au Führer
une version modifiée
par le général Olbricht,
le colonel Tresckow et lui-même,
des plans de l'opération Valkyrie.
Comme à son habitude,
Hitler va les signer sans même les lire.
Le piège s'est refermé.
Car ces plans modifiés
permettent à ceux qui les possèdent
de s'emparer de Berlin
en cas de trouble.
Tuer Hitler,
lancer l'opération Valkyrie
et mettre en place
un nouveau gouvernement.
Le destin de l'Allemagne
se trouve sur les genoux
du colonel Stauffenberg.
Après deux heures trente de vol,
Stauffenberg et von Haeften se présentent
aux portes de la Tanière du Loup.
Ouverture de la barrière.
Démarrez.
Devant eux
se dresse le bunker du Führer.
Derrière ces épais murs de béton
se tiennent habituellement
les réunions stratégiques.
C'est là que Stauffenberg veut frapper.
Une aubaine pour Stauffenberg,
car le béton renforce l'impact.
Le souffle mortel causé par l'explosion.
Mais ce jour-ci,
du fait de la chaleur excessive,
Hitler décide de tenir la réunion
dans un des baraquements de bois.
- Heil mon Führer.
- Le lieutenant-colonel Stauffenberg.
Lieutenant-colonel.
Le monde n'est pas
pour des peuples lâches.
Où puis-je me rafraîchir ?
12h20.
Après avoir salué le Führer et sa suite,
Stauffenberg demande à prendre congé
pour se rafraîchir
et changer de chemise.
Car la chaleur est étouffante.
Hitler et sa suite se dirigent
sans attendre vers la baraque,
Car mauvaise nouvelle
pour Stauffenberg,
la réunion
est avancée d'une demi-heure
du fait d'une visite dans l'après-midi
de Benito Mussolini.
J'avais demandé
à pouvoir me rafraîchir.
Il faisait très chaud.
Et mes blessures de guerre
bien apparentes
faisaient
qu'on me posait peu de questions.
Mais dans cette cabane en bois,
moins susceptible de renforcer l'explosion
que le bunker,
il semblait plus prudent
d'armer les deux engins explosifs.
Von Haeften m'a tendu la mallette
contenant les bombes.
Nous plaçâmes les détonateurs
sur les charges
et je commençai à régler
le premier minuteur. Soudain...
J'arrive !
- Lieutenant-colonel ?
- Oui !
... j'entends que quelqu'un m'appelle
à travers la porte.
- Lieutenant-colonel Stauffenberg ?
- Oui, j'arrive !
Un appel pour moi
du général Fellgiebel.
C'est urgent.
Une charge est réglée.
Plus de temps pour la deuxième.
Von Haeften l'emporte avec lui.
Une seule bombe.
Tant pis. Cela devrait suffire.
12h25.
Une vingtaine de hauts dignitaires
et généraux du Reich
sont réunis dans la pièce
autour d'Adolf Hitler.
Le maréchal Keitel
fait son rapport sur la situation à l'est.
Hitler, attentif, suit sur les cartes
les positions des troupes.
12h30.
Stauffenberg les rejoint.
Il salue son voisin.
Le colonel Heinz Brandt.
- Puis-je poser ma sacoche ici ?
- Bien sûr.
J'ai placé la sacoche sur le sol.
Sous la table.
Aux pieds du colonel Brandt.
Je lui dis que je la laisse là
quelques instants,
car j'ai un appel urgent
à donner à Berlin.
Personne ne s'étonne.
Dans ce genre de réunion,
tous les officiers sont très affairés
et beaucoup de coups de fil
sont échangés avec le front.
Tout est en place.
Ce n'est plus qu'une question de temps.
J'ai trouvé un nouveau prétexte
pour sortir de la pièce.
- Je dois passer un appel.
- Allez-y.
Gêné par la sacoche,
Brandt la déplace
pour l'appuyer
de l'autre côté de la table.
Par ce geste anodin mais fatidique,
le colonel Heinz Brandt
éloigne la bombe d'Hitler.
Il est temps.
Je vous attends.
12h40.
Stauffenberg a quitté le bâtiment.
Il ne reste plus qu'à attendre.
J'ai senti le souffle sur mes joues.
Hitler est mort.
Personne n'aurait pu survivre
à une telle explosion.
- Mon Général, où est le Führer ?
- Alerte !
- Le Führer dans la baraque !
La baraque est en partie soufflée,
éventrée.
La confusion est totale.
Les gardes accourent
pour relever les blessés des décombres.
Stauffenberg en est persuadé,
Hitler est mort.
Il vient de voir sa dépouille
sur un brancard.
Mon dos !
12h47.
Stauffenberg et von Haeften
remontent précipitamment en voiture.
Ils doivent rejoindre Berlin
au plus vite.
Mais le colonel von Stauffenberg
s'est trompé.
Hitler a survécu
et souffre seulement
de blessures superficielles.
Les conjurés pensaient
que leurs complices avaient coupé
les moyens de communication
de la Tanière du Loup avec Berlin.
Mais dans leur précipitation,
ceux-ci ont oublié quelques relais.
Des informations contradictoires
circulent déjà.
13h15.
Claus von Stauffenberg
décolle de l'aérodrome
en direction de Berlin.
Pour lui, l'opération est un succès.
Hitler est mort.
À Berlin, les ordres scellés
de l'opération Valkyrie
ont été distribués
et le gouvernement provisoire
constitué
sous la direction du général Beck.
À Berlin,
le général Olbricht
et le colonel Quirnheim,
tous deux de la conjuration,
attendent toujours une confirmation
pour lancer l'opération.
Trois précieuses heures sont perdues,
quand enfin Stauffenberg atterrit
et leur confirme la mort d'Adolf Hitler.
À 16 h, l'opération Valkyrie
est enfin lancée.
Tous les officiers
mobilisés pour Valkyrie
ont reçu une enveloppe scellée.
Dans l'enveloppe, des ordres brefs.
Tous les responsables SS,
ainsi que Goering,
Bormann, Himmler et Goebbels,
doivent être arrêtés immédiatement
et leurs hommes désarmés.
Mais rien ne se passe comme prévu.
Soudain, vers la fin d'après-midi
résonne dans tous les haut-parleurs
la voix du Führer.
"Une petite clique d'officiers ambitieux
sans scrupules
a ourdi un complot pour m'éliminer
et exterminer
l'état-major de l'armée allemande."
Hitler est bien vivant.
Il a revêtu un uniforme neuf
pour accueillir son ami Mussolini
à la descente du train.
Hitler confie à l'Italien
qu'il voit dans sa survie
la preuve irréfutable
que la Providence l'a choisi
pour la victoire finale.
Une sacoche déplacée,
un solide pied de table,
des murs de bois
qui ne renvoient pas l'onde de choc
et le temps
qui a manqué à Stauffenberg
pour armer sa dernière bombe.
Voilà les vraies raisons du miracle.
Alors qu'Hitler
fait ses adieux à Mussolini,
la répression
bat déjà son plein à Berlin,
Et elle va être implacable.
Défense...
Le major Otto Remer
qui commande le régiment de la garde
harangue ses troupes.
On lui avait demandé
d'arrêter Goebbels.
Il déclenche la chasse aux insurgés.
C'en est fini de l'opération Valkyrie.
Dans la soirée,
le général Olbricht,
le colonel von Quirnheim,
le lieutenant von Haeften
et le colonel von Stauffenberg
sont arrêtés et condamnés à mort,
sans procès, par le général Fromm.
Pour sa survie,
Fromm, sans hésiter,
trahit les conjurés.
Il faut que les témoins
de sa collaboration disparaissent.
En joue !
Vers minuit,
Stauffenberg et ses amis
sont exécutés.
Feu !
Ils sont enterrés comme des soldats,
avec leurs uniformes et médailles.
Mais Hitler, furieux,
fera brûler leurs cadavres
et disperser les cendres
dans un champ d'épandage.
Pour le comte Henning von Tresckow,
récemment promu général,
lui, l'âme,
la tête pensante
de la résistance à Hitler,
il est temps de faire son testament.
Pour protéger son épouse Erika
et ses enfants,
il a prévu de maquiller son suicide
en embuscade.
Les partisans russes sont nombreux
dans les forêts
et les attaques fréquentes.
Ce 21 juillet,
malgré la brume matinale,
il fait beau à Ostrow,
sur le front de l'Est.
C'est un homme tranquille,
en paix avec sa conscience,
qui salue son compagnon d'armes.
"Celui qui parvient à garder
ses rêves d'enfant dans la pureté,
à les conserver
sous sa poitrine nue
et sans défense,
celui qui malgré les rires de ce monde
ose vivre comme il l'a rêvé
dans son enfance
jusqu'au dernier jour,
oui, celui-là est un homme.
Un homme dans son entier.
Désormais, le monde entier
va se jeter sur nous
et nous traîner dans la boue.
Je suis cependant
intimement persuadé,
et je n'ai jamais varié sur ce point,
que nous avons bien fait d'agir
comme nous l'avons fait.
Je tiens Hitler
pour l'ennemi mortel de l'Allemagne,
mais aussi de l'humanité tout entière.
Quand, dans quelques heures,
je me présenterai
devant le tribunal de Dieu
pour rendre compte de mes décisions
et de mes actes,
je crois que je pourrai le faire
en bonne conscience.
Car je produirai
tout ce que j'ai entrepris contre Hitler.
De même que Dieu
promit autrefois à Abraham
de ne pas détruire Sodome
s'il y avait seulement
dix justes dans la ville,
de la même manière,
j'espère que par respect pour nous,
Dieu épargnera l'Allemagne.
J'aurais voulu
que vous fussiez témoins de ma mort.
Je ne veux pas laisser en plus
à nos ennemis
la satisfaction de m'arracher à la vie.
Au revoir.
Nous nous reverrons
dans un monde meilleur."
C'est en civil
et après avoir été dégradés
et exclus de l'armée
que les conjurés comparaissent.
Pour tous les conjurés,
une seule sentence : la peine de mort.
Le tribunal est présidé
par le juge Roland Freisler.
En quelques années de carrière,
ce juge a déjà fait exécuter
quelques milliers d'Allemands
opposants au régime.
Ils sont près de 200
à être envoyés à la potence.
Dont un maréchal,
19 généraux, 26 colonels,
deux ambassadeurs,
sept diplomates, un ministre,
trois secrétaires d'État
et le chef de la police du Reich.
Hitler l'avait exigé.
Il voulait les voir suspendus
comme des quartiers de viande
à des crocs de boucher.
Et pour la mort soit lente à venir,
et surtout douloureuse,
la corde de chanvre
est remplacée
par l'acier d'une corde à piano.
Et pour son plaisir extrême,
les exécutions sont filmées.
La mort n'est pas immédiate.
L'agonie peut durer 20 minutes.
Les bobines sont portées
chaque soir au QG d'Hitler.
500 Reichsmarks.
La note de frais
de l'administration judiciaire à Berlin
est envoyée
aux familles des suppliciés.
125 Reichsmarks
sont prévus comme salaire
au bourreau.
Ce jour du 18 octobre 1944,
des funérailles nationales
sont offertes par Hitler
à son maréchal préféré,
Erwin Rommel.
Dans son discours d'adieux,
le maréchal von Runstedt dit :
"Son cœur appartenait au Führer."
Mais quatre jours plus tôt, à midi,
deux généraux
se présentent au domicile de Rommel
pour lui proposer un sinistre marché.
Pendant l'enquête
sur l'opération Valkyrie,
le nom du maréchal
aurait été prononcé
au cours d'interrogatoires.
Alors, sur ordre du Führer,
lui est proposé l'infamie d'un procès
ou la mort par suicide
avec les honneurs,
et la garantie que rien
n'arriverait à sa famille.
Rommel,
après avoir embrassé son épouse
et son fils Manfred,
monte dans la voiture avec les officiers.
Cinq minutes plus tard,
il avale deux capsules de cyanure.
Le héros des Allemands
venait officiellement
de mourir d'une embolie.
Hitler avait menacé le monde
de déchaîner la tempête.
Mais aujourd'hui,
c'est sur l'Allemagne
que la tempête
crache ses dernières flammes.
Depuis l'attentat manqué
à la brasserie, le 8 novembre 1939,
Georg Elser est un détenu particulier.
On le surnomme "le prisonnier secret"
ou "le prisonnier d'Hitler".
Au camp de Dachau,
ce matin du 9 avril 1945,
sur un ordre
venu du Führer en personne,
deux SS viennent abattre Elser
dans sa cellule.
20 jours plus tard,
les troupes américaines
libèrent le camp de Dachau.
20 jours trop tard
pour sauver l'homme
qui avait voulu tuer Hitler.
Le 21 avril 1945,
les premiers obus soviétiques
atteignent Berlin.
Il va en tomber plus de deux millions.
Pour stopper les T34,
les tanks soviétiques,
des armes sont distribuées
aux vieillards et aux enfants.
Les derniers soldats du Führer
n'ont pas 12 ans.
Après les avoir salués
et envoyés à la mort,
Hitler retourne
s'enterrer dans son bunker.
Il n'en sortira plus jamais vivant.
La bataille de Berlin
va durer plus de dix jours.
Un combat acharné, désespéré.
Rien ne peut plus résister
aux Soviétiques.
Les pertes sont terribles
de part et d'autre.
Deux mille chars soviétiques
sont mis hors de combat,
et certains par des soldats
qui sont encore des enfants.
La ville ne veut pas
se rendre aux Russes.
Mais il est trop tard.
Le Reich, qui devait durer 1 000 ans,
est en train de s'effondrer.
À 1 h du matin,
le dimanche 29 avril,
Eva Braun, la maîtresse d'Hitler
depuis 13 ans,
épouse son Führer
au cours d'une courte cérémonie.
Goebbels et Bormann sont les témoins,
assistés d'un officier d'État civil.
Quelques coupes de mousseux
sont échangées
avec le dernier carré de fidèles.
Eva Braun rayonne.
Elle est maintenant Frau Hitler.
Vers 3 h du matin,
Hitler dicte à sa secrétaire
son testament privé.
Trois pages dactylographiées
où il annonce :
"Moi-même et mon épouse
choisissons la mort
pour échapper à la honte
de la destitution ou de la capitulation.
Notre volonté est d'être brûlés
immédiatement sur place."
Lundi 30 avril,
le drapeau rouge flotte
sur le Reichstag et Berlin.
À 15h30, Hitler rejoint sa chambre,
accompagné d'Eva, son épouse.
Elle a choisi le poison,
lui se tire une balle dans la tempe.
À 15h50,
les deux cadavres sont transportés
à l'extérieur du bunker.
200 litres d'essence
sont déversés sur les corps
et le feu y est mis.
Beaucoup avaient voulu tuer Hitler.
Mais il s'est tué de sa propre main.
À la date choisie
et au cœur même de sa capitale.
Berlin.
La guerre est une folie.
Il faut l'arrêter.
Le personnage central est Hitler.
Il faut le tuer.
Le monde doit être délivré
du plus grand criminel
de tous les temps.
Nous devons l'abattre.
Comme un chien enragé
qui menace l'humanité tout entière.
Ils étaient guidés
par leur courage et leur honneur.
Tresckow, Schlabrendorff,
Gersdorff,
Stauffenberg,
Elser.
Tous ont voulu tuer Hitler.
Tous ont échoué.
Si un seul de ces hommes avait réussi,
des millions de vies humaines
auraient été sauvées.
Et la face du monde, changée.